certains médias ont rapporté dans les
derniers jours que la pandémie pourrait
causer une augmentation de 40% du prix
de détail de la viande de boeuf de porc
et de poulet l'explosion de la demande
la diminution des importations en
provenance des états unis et
l'augmentation des exportations
canadiennes en seraient les causes
or il s'avère que si les tablettes se
vide rapidement
c'est parce que les gens n'achètent en
plus grande quantité et qu'on n'a pas le
temps de les remplir
parce que dans les faits l'offre ne
manque pas d'ailleurs vérification faite
à travers le pays
les prix de détail sont actuellement
moins élevé qu'à pareille date l'an
dernier l'augmentation anticipée elle ne
devrait pas dépasser les 5 à 7%
alors gardez l'oeil ouvert